en este vídeo vamos a encontrar cuánto
vale el límite cuando x tiende a cero de
uno menos coseno de x / x y lo que vamos
a suponer en esta ocasión y esto es muy
importante es que el límite cuando x
tiende a cero del seno de x / x es igual
a 1 en esta ocasión no probaré de nuevo
este límite pero existe otro vídeo
completo en la canaca deming dedicado a
probar este famoso límite usando el
teorema de comparación del sándwich
bueno intentemos ahora probar el límite
inicial así que lo primero que haremos
es manipular algebraica mente esta
expresión multiplicando tanto el
numerador como el denominador por uno
más coseno de x
ok y para el denominador hay que hacer
lo mismo lo voy a multiplicar por uno
más
el coseno de x
y bueno no estoy cambiando el valor de
esta expresión esto es simplemente
multiplicar por 1 pero en que nos ayudan
bueno es que ahora puedo reescribir toda
esta expresión como el límite cuando
extiende a 0 de i observa 1 - coseno de
x por uno más coseno de x esto es igual
a bueno uno elevado al cuadrado lo cual
es uno menos coseno de x elevado al
cuadrado lo cual es coseno cuadrado de x
es una diferencia de cuadrados y en el
denominador voy a tener que esto es
simplemente pues x por uno más posee no
de x ahora cuánto es uno menos coseno
cuadrado de x bueno si usamos la famosa
identidad trivundza métrica pitagórica
esto es lo mismo que el seno cuadrado de
x y por lo tanto puede reescribir todo
esto como el límite cuando x tiende a
cero
dm y bueno en lugar de escribir el seno
cuadrado de x voy a escribirlo como el
seno de x por el seno de x
déjame escribirlo seno de x por el seno
de x entonces me queda el límite cuando
existente a cero en el seno de x / x
tomándome solamente el primer seno de x
y dividiéndolo entre esta x seno de x /
x x y ahora me tomaré el segundo seno de
x y lo voy a dividir entre 1 + coseno de
x seno de x entre 1 + coseno de x hasta
este momento lo único que he hecho es
usar la identidad trigonométricas
pitagórica y manipular la expresión de
una manera algebraica bien aquí tengo el
límite del producto de dos expresiones
así que esto es lo mismo que el producto
de los límites esto va a ser igual al
límite cuando x tiende a cero de seno de
x / x de acero de x / x por el límite
cuando x tiende a 0 del seno de x entre
1 + coseno de x
pero ya sabemos cuánto vale el límite
cuando x tiende a cero de seno de x / x
fue lo que dijimos el inicio del vídeo
me recuerdas cuánto vale el límite
cuando x tiende a cero de seno de x / x
bueno como puedes ver acá arriba dijimos
que es igual a 1 así que este límite se
reduce simplemente a saber cuánto vale
este otro límite así que veamos qué es
lo que pasa con él si ahora sustituimos
por el valor de cero porque x se
aproxima a cero
entonces observa en el numerador esto se
aproxima a 0 seno de 0 0 y el
denominador se aproxima bueno conociendo
de cero es 1 entonces lo de abajo se
aproxima a 2 es algo distinto de 0 y por
lo tanto toda esta expresión se está
aproximando a 0 entre 2 o simplemente a
0 y 1 por 0 0 y eso quiere decir que
todo este límite es simplemente cero y
ya hemos acabado usando este límite que
escribimos en un principio y algunas
identidades trigonométricas y bastante
manipulación
es sencilla llegamos al resultado
pudimos demostrar que nuestro límite
original el límite cuando x tiende a 0
de 1 - coseno de x / x es igual a 0 y te
encargo que lo graphic es para que veas
que en efecto esto tiene todo el sentido
del mundo y así también lo compruebes de
una manera visual nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo